>>>DANIEL FRIEDMAN: All right. Hello and welcome, everyone.
It's December 7, 2022.
This is Active Inference live stream
number 31.1. We are here with Brett
Kagan and we're going to be hearing a
presentation and having a discussion on
free energy principle and active
inference in synthetic biological
intelligence. We'll have a presentation
followed by a discussion, so feel free
to submit any questions if you would
like. Brett, thank you for joining.
Really looking forward to this
presentation and discussion. Off to you.
>>>BRETT KAGAN: Thanks so much, Daniel, and thank you.
Everyone joining us today. Hopefully
we've got some interesting stuff. So
what I want to talk to you about is the
work that we've been doing in what we
call synthetic biological intelligence,
and particularly the use we've made of
principles from the free energy
principle and active Inference
frameworks. So if
we jump to sort of the first question
and we can kind of ask ourselves,
because we work with neural systems,
what is there that's unique about neural
systems? And one of the obvious answers
to that is that they display this unique
ability to collate information and apply
it in an adaptive behavior in multiple
contexts. And that could be a fitting
definition for intelligence, if you
like. But to actually be
able to test this in actual cells in
real time, what you have to do is be
able to record the information from the
cells and provide information back to
the cells in real time. So how did we go
about setting this up? How did we get
these cells? So we did it in two ways.
Either we took what's called a human
induced pluripotent stem cell. That's
the hiPSC there that you can see.
And what you can do is develop these
from any donor blood, tissue or skin.
And you can basically make a pluripotent
stem cell line. And then you can use a
number of different methods to turn that
into neurons of quite a degree of
specificity. We used quite a broad one
force, most of our work, which is called
a jewel smad inhibition, which follows
like, natural ontological development,
or ontogeney development, I should say,
to sort of create these
predominantly cortical cultures in a
dish. But you can use other direct
methods such as what's called an
Ngntirect differentiation, which gives
rise to a more excitatory culture. Then
we also took primary cortical
neurocultures from mouse and we drew
them as a competition because we wanted
to make sure that we were using, at
least in some sense, bona fide cortical
neurons. And the best way to do that is
to take it from animals. But
fortunately, as you see, we will be able
to move, and we have moved away from
that now in our current practice. So
we're completely animal testing free at
the moment. And then what we did was we
plated these onto what's called a high
density multiletrode array. And
essentially I'll show you a bit more of
this in a second. This is essentially a
CMOs chip, which is a type of chip that
you might get in a digital camera. But
it's also can be used in this purpose
because what it can do is sense
electrical signals, even very small
ones, and actually be able to stimulate
to them. And so just
some evidence that we actually did do
the work we said we did. Here's some
examples of some cultures that we've
grown, and they show what we're able to
do is use techniques to actually capture
key markers of aspects of these cells.
So, for example, this Bleu over here,
hopefully it's coming up all right on
your screens. This shows something
called DAPI, which marks all the nucleus
of any cell. If you want, you can look
at something called new. And here new
and marks neurons. So all the green dots
and you might be able to see a bit
better in this picture, all the green
dots show that this is actually a
neuron. And then, of course, one of the
things that we know neurons have is that
they send out axons. And that's what
this thing called, beta three tubulin
marks in the red. And finally, we want
to know, do they have dendrites? And you
can see here in the purple, this is
marking dendrites. Also a little bit of
axons, but it also marks dendrites as
well. And then more than that, we want
to know is not just are they neurons,
because most neurons will have those
traits, but also are they cortical
neurons? And BRN one is actually a
marker for cortical neurons. You can see
here actually, not only are they
neurons, but most of those neurons are
cortical. Specifically, there's of
course, going to be different cell types
in there. For example, GFAP here mark
supporting cell types such as glia. And
you can see here we have a number of
glia. You can also really obviously see
that these glia, these in the bigger
picture, have quite a different
morphology than the neurons. So it's
nice that we have sort of this mixed
population because it means that we're
able to test something that has some
degree of comparable characteristics
to what you might see in an animal or
in our cortical areas. Of course,
it's much, much simpler magnitudes and
magnitude simpler than that. But it is
reassuring for the function to know that
there are some similarities as a model.
And importantly for anyone who has
looked at sort of creating cells out of
stem cells, one of the big problems is
that not all of those cells might be
fully differentiate. And if you do have
cells that aren't differentiate that are
still pouriponent when you put them in a
dish, they can turn into anything. And
of course, most of the time what they
turn into is something invasive and
potentially cancerous, depending what it
is. Fortunately, this KR 67 marks
dividing cells. So this would sort of
mark any cell that wasn't fully
differentiated. And this is a case
where we had none of them and that was
common, but generally we had none to
very, very few. And because of that,
we're actually able to have these
cultures growing for extended periods of
time. And this is what's action
planning, electron microscopy image. So
these are real biological neurons.
They're a little cracked because when
you do the cryo aspect of the scanning
and you freeze them for the necessary
preparation, they do tend to crack a
bit. But you can still mostly see that
there are a lot of intact neurons, a lot
of connections, and then behind that you
can actually see all the electrodes and
you can also see the density and the
complexity of this. And this is actually
an area of the chip that is less dense
and interconnected than some of the
other areas because if you look at the
ones that are highly dense and
interconnected, you can't see the chip
behind it. We kind of wanted to show the
fact that there's a chip behind this.
And I think one of the key things to
take away from this simply is the degree
of complexity you get here compared to
something like an artificial neural
network. A lot of the time people look
at models and they're quite nice and
neat and symmetrical and that's just not
what happens in biology. And as we'll
discuss later, there's probably some
interesting features that arise out of
this degree and this extent of random
or pseudorandom connectivity. And so
what we could then do with this
technology is map out this is an example
of like, the chip surface and then the
firing rate in hertz can be seen here as
a color scale. And we can see over time
with different cell types, we can get
their activity and different cell types
sort of turn on or begin to become
active at different times. But
importantly, what we can do is get a
fairly even distribution of active cells
over the surface area fairly
consistently. Again, anyone who works in
this area knows there's a fair bit of
variation inherently and that's stuff
we're working on now for the future.
But we are able to get this degree of
activity over time and that gives us
some useful cell cultures to test. Of
course. How do we go about testing that?
Which is the big question. And we know
that as a living organism, you, me,
mice, cats, whatever, we need to have
the closed loop feedback to operate.
And what does that mean? Essentially,
it means that we're able to receive
information about the outcomes of our
actions and modify our actions as a
result of it. So if I reach over for a
cell phone, I immediately get sensory
feedback in a number of modalities as I
do that action. And as I pick it up,
I'm aware of the success of it. If I
fail, I'm aware of that too. And this is
actually this little mouse with a VR
headset from this Attenger study, which
is one of my favorite studies that's
been done in recent times where they
actually attached their virtual reality
to mice. And I found that if they
disconnected the mouse's movement as it
was developing from the actual visual
information it got, it led to quite
catastrophic developmental,
functional developmental impairments.
And it just really shows it shouldn't be
surprising so much, but it does show us
like that this link with our environment
is incredibly important for us as
organisms to develop. And so if you're
looking at cells in a dish and you want
to try and elicit intelligence, you can
immediately say, well, you need to have
some sort of linkage, some Embodiment,
which is active through this closed loop
system to be set up. And so one of
the better ways to sort of do this is to
contrast it with an open feedback system
because that's what people generally do.
So just to emphasize this closed loop
means that we stimulate some sort of
sensation and that can be done with an
electrical stimulation. And we can
provide then a sensory feedback, again
through electrical stimulation on how
that response alters the world. And it's
actually been demonstrated before in a
few studies, for example, in this back
and paper, that this closed loop
stimulation does result in increased
plasticity.
But we wanted to try and take it a
little further and actually see if we
could elicit a very clear goal directed
behavior. And so we set up this is a
little schematic of the dish. And what
we did was we almost arbitrarily defined
I shouldn't say it's arbitrary because
there was a lot of planning and strategy
behind it. But what I mean by this is
that within a given framework, for
example, here, what we did was we
designated a sensory region where we put
information into electrodes using a
combination of rate and place encoding.
And then we read it out in this sort of
counterbalanced region here. So activity
in these two regions would make the
paddle move up. Activity in these two
regions would make the paddle move down.
But the reason I say it's arbitrary was
that we were able to basically change
this configuration to a number of ways
and for the most part, although there
were some differences, get a degree of
statistically significant performance.
And that, of course, just shows the fact
that neurons as, again, shouldn't be a
surprise to anybody, are incredibly
plastic and able to adapt and change how
they respond otherwise. And I think
that's a really interesting thing
because, of course, starting out here,
there is no real reason why neuron
should behave in any particular way
unless they're doing it to accord to
some fundamental imperative. And this is
just an example of the visualization.
You're actually able to go there's a
site. If you jump to our website, we'll
show that later. It's called Spikestream
and you can go and play around with this
yourself. It's available. So this is an
example of the electrode multiletrode
ray. Each little dot is a potential
electrode we can route. The Bleu ones
are the ones we're routing at the
moment. Each little bar is an activity
and you can see we put activity in the
top and then we read it out at the
bottom and it moves these paddle. And
over time, as I'll show you, it gets
better. Feel free to go to the spike
stream and have a look at that. But
right now what I want to discuss is,
yes, it's all well and good that a
system may be able to organize its
behavior in a changing environment. And
this is actually an example of a very
successful so these are actual neurons
driving this paddle. So it's an example
of one of our more successful cultures.
But by no means is it a weird exception.
We do see this sort of better
performance fairly often. Again, there
is variation, of course, and one of the
ways that we wanted to investigate this
initially was this idea of the free
energy principle, which I'm sure many of
you are familiar with. So I'm not going
to go into it in a great amount of
detail, but I will provide kind of like
a higher level summary of it Beren and
the key things that we can sort of boil
it down to in a very oversimplified
sense. Essentially it means that what we
want to do with the Frenchie principle,
it suggests that there is an innate
generative or a system to actually match
a prediction that it makes to incoming
sensation. And this can be phrased in
Bayesian terms and there's a lot of
implications one can take from that.
And I love this picture that Karl
Friston wrote up in his or developed as
part of his Nature Neuroscience Reviews
article. If you haven't seen it, read
it. It's a great article. It covers a
lot of good stuff, but simply between
the linkages between the different
levels of the system. And of course it
is. And one of the strong arguments for
it is that being able to predict and act
in your environment is theoretically
necessary. And the other implication,
of course, is that there needs to be a
statistical boundary between the
internal and the external, which is
called a micro blanket. And we're going
to touch on that a bit more later.
Diving into the notion of active
inference via the free energy principle,
formally, it's sort of been stated that
this is a process of minimizing
variation of free energy through action
and perception. And essentially what
it's saying here is that a living
organism is going to actively generate
this internal model of the external
world and then align those models. And
broadly speaking, there's two ways we
can do that, either perception or
action. So if I use my cell phone as an
example before, if I reach over, pick it
up, what I've done is I've created a
model in my head based on the visual
information I've received, where the
cell phone is. I've reached over, I've
picked it up, very good. My perception
matched, matched my reality. Let's say
though, that I didn't and I dropped it
as I tried to pick it up. Well, what
could I do? Either I could get better at
predicting the world and say look, when
I reach, I will always drop my cell
phone or I could get better at defining
where it is in the world. All what I
could do is get better at the actual
reaching action. And really when you
boil down to it, these are the only two
ways that a system can get better at
predicting its environment, either
through getting better prediction or
getting better at controlling the
environment. And so for our cell
culture, what we wanted to do was simply
remove one of these options. So it's a
very simple implication from a very
nuanced theory. But following
that, we sort of said if the world
became truly random, something that like
we as people, like you can't
anthropomorphicize this too much because
like we as people can't really
experience something that's truly
random, but in addition with random
noise, you could at least approximate
it.
That's what we did. And so we had these
two options. So what we then said is
that this is true. What the cells will
do is actually change their action to
make it accord with the internal model
of the world that they have to decide
and derive from the sensory stimulation
we feed them. So under this model here,
that's sort of represented in this
picture that you can see, what we
propose is that the neural cells or the
system will try to minimize the
difference between the internal and the
external world to minimize the free
energy of the system, ie. Minimize their
surprising. And we kind of predicted
whether aversive is the right word or
not. It would certainly we would say
that nonpredictable random stimulation
should be something that the cells would
try to avoid. While on the flip side,
if we gave them a predictable stimulus
when they did something they like that
might be reinforcing. And again,
whether I put these words in quotes
because there's a whole language
question no one could have a question
around what is it, is it truly aversive?
Is it driving? Is it whatever? But for
the sake of communication, we have to
pick words right now so hopefully you
understand the context in which they're
used. And so what we propose then is
that the cells should modify their
activity to avoid adopting a state. In
this case, that's a pattern of activity
that would lead to an increase in
surprise. And so what we can see here,
we set up some experimental tests and we
compared a number of different methods.
So we compared this control group. This
was simply media in a dish that had the
stimulations and feedback applied to it.
Media and a dish should not be able to
learn without any cells. We had an in
silicone model that would drive the
pattern with random noise. And
essentially this was to test the control
group. You can think the media only
control group, I should say you can
think of it as testing. Were we able to
get activity simply through our
stimulation? The encilico was saying
could we get performance simply through
something in the system itself making
sure that the system isn't biased in any
obvious way. Then we had a rest control
group where there were cells in a dish
but no stimulation. And this was asking
the question left alone, will the
spontaneous activity of neurons because
neurons always have activity regardless
of whether you're stimulating them or
not will that lead to better
performance? Again, there's no reason it
should if our system is set up properly.
Of course, if there's a bias, it would,
but that's what we're testing here. And
then finally we had both mouse and human
cells that were given the information
where the ball was were given feedback
and were able to play the game. And what
you can see is basically this
is a little hard to interpret this graph
if you don't stare at heat maps all day.
But if you compare, say, just the top
right, which is the number of hips that
are occurring in any given minute by the
minute on the x axis, you can see that
it doesn't really change too much over
time for the control group. But compare
it and obviously the encilicone, the
resting controls are kind of the same as
that. If you compare it to the mouse
and, say, the human cultures you can see
quite a clear difference here. And if
you want more asteroids for significance
because who doesn't love asterisks? At
least all scientists love asterisks or
other symbols of significance. What we
can do is you can see over time this
control groups, the media controlled in
silicon controlled or rest control they
don't show any difference over time. A
bit of variation, but ultimately no real
significant difference over time. In
contrast, the mouse and the human cells
both showed learning over time. And by
the second time point they outperformed
all the other cultures, all the other
conditions. I should say.
Interestingly, the human cells even
ended up slightly outperforming the
mouse cells. And although I would be
careful not to overinterpret this it was
interesting to note that we've run this
experiment a number of times and this is
a very consistent difference. And so it
could be an interesting way to start to
investigate differences in the future
between species. If one wanted to set up
a study more rigorously to actually test
this and these results were replicated
it wasn't like we found one measure that
suddenly looked like performance and we
ignored the rest. We looked at a number
of them. Some of the other interesting
ones are stuff like the percentage of
long rallies where it's hit the ball
more than three times in a row. So force
four plus in a row and
you can see here again significantly
changes over the time for the mouse and
human cells, nothing for the others.
Likewise the aces, which is like tennis,
where they miss the ball without even
hitting at once. This decreases
statistically significantly over time
for the mouse and human cortical cells,
not for the others. So much so that's
interesting, but we sort of say like,
well it's interesting, it shouldn't be
surprising because we know that neural
cells are adaptive and the fact you can
see it in a dish is cool. But what
are the implications? What can this
actually teach us about how these cells
are behaving? And one of the things
people have looked at in detail
previously is functional plasticity.
So what we looked at here is, of course
we also assessed functional activity and
saw that there was a massive difference
between the resting state functional
plasticity and the gameplay functional
plasticity. But what does
that actually mean? What does that
actually look like, going beyond just
the fact that there's plasticity
occurring in the culture. So what you
can do is you can look here at just the
correlation and the activity between the
cells in the motor regions that I've
shown you before and the sensory
regions. And it's not too surprising
that whether or not they're playing the
game, you have quite a high degree of
correlation. In fact, the correlations
at Rest are slightly stronger than the
correlations at gameplay. But what is
interesting actually is if you take the
average correlation, not just what is
the overall correlation, but you
actually break down the average
correlation per culture and session.
What you do is you actually get a far
higher average correlation between the
sensory and motor regions when they're
playing the game than when they're at
risk. This makes sense if you need to
coordinate your action with incoming
stimulation, you need to have a degree
of correlation between where you receive
that action and the activity there and
where at your activity outputs going
out. But conversely, if you have in
this case, basically you can think of it
as two buttons even though they're
spread over four regions, what you would
actually need to have is a negative
correlation or a reduced correlation
between these regions. And if you look
at the percentage of exclusive motor
region activity in this graph, which is
where you have activity in either the up
or the down region and bear in mind,
again, these are counterbalanced. So
this result is actually pretty
interesting to see. What you see here
is that during Rest versus gameplay you
actually have a higher degree of
exclusive motor region activity, which
would of course be necessary for
discrete control in one direction versus
the other. And this was quite an
exciting result because it was really
supportive sort of that there is
something quite dynamics and interesting
going on in the way that these cultures
are reorganizing their activity. And
likewise, this actually just shows the
degree that this correlation decreases
over time with two linear regressions
and you get two very different linear
regressions over the first 5 minutes and
the last 15. And we arbitrarily, just
based on some early work, decided to and
again, not super arbitrarily, but based
on some early work, I should say, we
decided to sort of split the games up
into the first and stabilize. And so
that was quite supportive to suggest
that what we're seeing here is really
the tapping in of some of the key
adaptive properties of the neural
cultures and to take it further focus
on the sort of free energy implications
here we can of course reframe surprise
it has a link with information entropy.
And as for those of you familiar, this
is of course to catch it as a kale just
divergence between the two distributions
of what might be occurring. And so we
wanted to actually calculate here the
information entropy of the actual
cultures. And now it's important to note
here this is entorhinal to the cultures
both at gameplay and at rest. And if we
didn't normalize it, there's quite a lot
of variation going on in any given
culture. But it becomes much clearer
once you do normalize it simply to
baselines. And you can see here that
when you give them random feedback so
one thing I'll say firstly is that the
gameplay normally actually has much
lower information entropy than when
they're at rest. Two, when you give them
random feedback, their information
entropy increases massively, thereby
suggesting that these cells indeed
should be under the French principle
should be predisposed to avoid this.
And that's actually what we saw. But
what we're interested in is to say well,
what if we tried different types of
feedback? Like how do we know this is
all well and good, but how do we know
that this type of feedback is actually
what's leading to these results?
Because it could be anything. And so we
set out and we introduced a few other
control conditions. So this is our
regular one that I've sort of was
showing you before if it was a bit
unclear, hopefully this helps to clear
it up a bit. When they played the game,
they missed the ball, they get random,
unpredictable sensory feedback. When
they hit the ball, they get predictable.
We then added something we called the
silent condition, which is when they
missed a ball, they basically had all
their feedback removed. And yet when
they hit the ball, nothing. They didn't
get any additional feedback. The game
just continued. Now, it is important to
note, of course, that when the game
restarts, after a missed, the direction
of the ball is random. So there is still
some randomness in this game,
but presumably less so than in the
normal stem condition. And this can be
contrasted with this open loop or no
feedback condition. There are synonyms
in this case, basically, where the game
is played, information about where the
ball is is presented to the cells
or the system cells or controls,
whatever the case is.
But if they miss, they don't get
anything changed. If they hit, they
don't get anything changed. And so
really it's asking a question like will
culture just play the game for the sake
of playing the game? There's no reason
it should, but maybe they do. So we
wanted to test that. And then the final
condition we included here, of course,
is a rest condition. And if this helps
to make it clear, if you're more
graphical, this can give you an example.
So here you can see the ball going up,
it hits it, and then you've got like a
predictable stimulation here. The ball
goes, it continues and it gets hit again
and then it misses and it gets a random
feedback. And then the game continuum
silent. In contrast, you can see that
this random feedback here at the same
time point is removed for the silent
condition. Likewise, there's no
predictable stimulation across the
culture and then there's no feedback.
It's just the ball becomes completely
predictable from the very first serve.
There is no unpredictability in it at
all. And so when we look at the results
here, and obviously, if you're
interested, you can go look at the paper
because we dive into this in similar
detail as before. But just in brief,
what I'll show you is that here, what
we've done is just compared it to rest
because it helps control the variability
a little bit and it makes it look a
little neater. But essentially, the
stimulus condition, they outperform
rest, they outperform their starting
position. Over time, it replicates what
we saw in the first study. And the
silent one, there is a very slight
increase. It doesn't reach statistical
significance, but they do end up also
statistically slightly better than a no
feedback condition, which shows pretty
much no learning compared to rest at
all. So that matches up pretty much with
what we expect to see around the free
free energy principle condition that
gets a small amount of randomness,
shows a small amount of learning, if you
want to do that, but not a MOT.
Something that gets a lot of random
information as a result of an action
that we deem undesirable, shows a
greater tendency to avoid that action.
And something that has no incentive to
behave in a particular way, doesn't
behave in a particular way. But what was
really interesting and exciting for us
also, although I'll be honest, it made
us stop for a few minutes to actually
think about why this chaos happened was.
That when you look at this normalized
information entropy, again, we got a
replication that when you gave them
random feedback, the actual internal
information entropy goes up. With the
silent condition, the information
entropy also went up, in fact, even more
so. And we went, why would this be the
case? And of course, what we realized
quite quickly was, well, neurons left
alone do fire spontaneously. And when
you take a neuron from a stimulated
condition to an unstimulated condition,
they do tend to re engage with the
random spontaneous activity quite
vigorously straight away. And yet
it didn't show the same degree of
learning. So of course, like I will say,
this is one finding that absolutely
needs to be followed up more in the
future and we are doing that. But it
does have an interesting implication in
terms of Markov blankets. So I mentioned
this before, I flagged it before and
this is why. Because I think this is one
of the really interesting results. So to
go Hinton more detail, what a Markov
blanket is, is it's a statistical
boundary that can distinguish an
internal state from an external state.
And this can be at any level. So it
could be at an individual neuron, a
cluster of neurons, nuclear distinct
functional regions of the brain, the
whole brain, the body, in correlation to
the rest of the world or what's outside
it. And so the fact that, as I
was saying, that we see that the silent
condition even shows more randomness
or information entropy than when we're
actually providing external random
information into the system is actually
very consistent with what we know about
the stochasticity of spontaneous
activity. But what it does also suggest
is that cells will respond differently
to randomness inside a system versus
outside a system. And that was a really
exciting result to sort of find allostat
physical evidence that perhaps this
Markov blanket really exists. Of course
it makes sense. It exists theoretically.
There's a lot of reasons, even just the
simplest notion that we can separate
what our internal thoughts are from
someone's external thoughts,
someone's external voice to us, I should
say, suggests that we need to have some
sort of barrier to distinguish these
types of structured information, one
internally, one external. But seeing it
was very interesting. And so we
also wanted to, of course, extend beyond
this and sort of not just stop here and
look at what other interesting things
might be happening. And one of the other
interesting findings that we've recently
completed, and there's a preprint of
this up now, is this idea of
neurocriticality. And so what is
criticality for those who aren't very
familiar with it, in brief, it is this
state where a population's activity is
coordinated basically between two other
states. So physically you could think of
it at that point between where water
becomes ice and as a point just in
between, which is a transition to bring
it back to the brain you can think of it
as a brain. That firing rate could be
either highly coordinated, rhythmic
oscillatory, much as, like, when we
sleep, or in catatonia, or it could be
completely disorganized, like in some
cases of epilepsy. And that then there's
a middle ground, and there's obviously
quite a spectrum, so there's quite a lot
of middle ground. But the closer you get
to this sort of critical transition
point this is called criticality, and
theoretically, it's been proposed to
maximize give me there's my time ant
telling me to take a break. It's
theoretically, it's been proposed to act
as a key criteria to maximize
information transmission and capacity.
And what's also really interesting is
that it's been linked to a number of
different cognitive behavior, although
the field is certainly a bit unclear
about what that is. So it's
Beren linked, for example, to responses
to drugs, working memory, attention.
One of my particular favorites is cores
of fluid intelligence.
But these studies have some concerns
with how they investigate it. And
ultimately, one of the biggest concerns
is that they're doing these ones. At
least in humans, we have lots of
compensatory mechanisms. You have to use
fMRI or mostly fMRI measures
to actually investigate it. So there's a
lot of barriers in actually concluding
this. So we set up a study to actually
investigate this. And essentially,
again, to not go into too much detail
about the nuances, we looked at three
key different metrics. There's been a
bit of criticism in the field where
people focus predominantly on power
laws. Power laws can arise from noise
alone. So we wanted to avoid that
shortfall and look at three different
measures. And so this is sort of the set
up we had. We took them, we compared
them either playing the game or at rest,
which I described to you before. And
then we looked at these things called
the DCC, the branching ratio or the
shape collapse error. And we wanted to
see how we could group them.
Sorry, my slides have frozen.
Let me try to jump to the next one. All
righty, so hopefully that's back for
everyone. Now, let me just there we go.
Okay, so what we saw here really
surprisingly, was a very stark
difference in criticality across
a number of measures. So you can just
see here, basically, the prediction
between the Rest and the Active is quite
just noticeably by eye, very different.
And of course, that's statistically
significant. Diving into more detail,
we could look at these different
measures. And this is just some quick
overview of what those different
measures look like. So the DCC,
the branching ratio. So, for example,
with branching ratio, critical systems
sort of maintained the number of threads
of activity that might happen. In a sub
critical system, that variation will die
off over time. In a supercritical
system, it's going to continue to expand
up into a point, and then there's a
shape collapse error, of course, which
is looking to see how you can collapse
different avalanche shapes across a
given spectrum. And then looking across
all of these, we get quite strong
statistical differences, showing quite
clearly that when you have the system
embodied in an environment, it's showing
this measure of criticality, which is
very interesting. And one of the
interesting things for this, actually,
is that it shows that this criticality
is very fundamental and that information
input seems to drive it very strongly.
And to us, this does seem like a
challenge, suggesting that it is in
itself inherently a marker of some sort
of higher order system.
But of course, I think the most
interesting thing is simply that we can
identify this and then what it does is
open up the possibility to further
investigate it with more nuanced tests
that were explicitly designed to
investigate criticality. But what was
nice also to see like, I guess, some
suggestion that it does have a role in
some sort of information processing in
some degree, is the fact that he is also
just showing you these results in a
slightly different measure. But looking
at the correlation, there were some
statistically significant correlations
between the different measures of
criticality and the gameplay
performance, showing that cultures that
showed higher degrees of criticality
across all three markers also had better
gameplay performance in this hitmiss
ratio, where they hit the ball more
often than they missed it. Which was,
of course, interesting to see. And does
suggest that although we
think that because this is arising in
such a simple system, with such simple
input, that it's unlikely to represent,
or at least in of itself be a criteria
for intelligence per se, that there
certainly is some link between
processing information and criticality.
And if you want a more nuanced
discussion of this, please feel free.
There's a preprint up now, all the
papers going through peer review. We
discuss it in more detail there. And
finally, what I would say, though, is
that just to sort of really hammer home
the point that this is a very
fundamental property of these cultures
and that it is so drastically different
when they're playing the game, versus
rest. That when we wanted to classify
ourselves based on criticality metrics
and performance as either playing the
game or Rest. We were able to do this
with a 98% success rate. If you took
Hinton performance, and even if you just
ignored performance and you just looked
at criticality with random forest,
we're able to do this with a 92% success
rate of characterizing, whether they're
playing the game or at Rest. And that's
that's obviously suggested this is very
fundamental, that once there's
information input in these cells,
they drastically reorganize their
activity. And that's really interesting.
Of course, one of the questions that we
also get asked a lot when we sort of put
out this early work was a lot of people
would say, oh, but who cares? We
literally had someone write a comment.
One of the peer reviewers, not in the
actually at one of the points said to us
but this can't actually do anything
better than reinforcement learning. So
how can you conclude anything about
biology? Which was a surprising comment
to get, but what we
wanted to do and said fair enough. Like
we think there's plenty you can learn
about biology, whether or not it does
better or worse in reinforcement
learning. But it's a fair question.
Like does this do performance wise? Can
it do anything interesting compared to
reinforcement learning? We know that if
you run reinforcement learning enough,
you will get superhuman affordance with
the game of Pong. They will solve it.
They'll be humans, that's fine. They can
do the same with protein foldings chest
go. That's all well and good, but that
does that mean that there is no room for
a biological system when it comes to
this? So what we wanted to do was
actually compare it for sample
efficiency because that is of course
something that reinforcement learning
struggles with greatly. So what we did
was we compared three different deep
learning algorithms, DQN, ATC and PPO
with three different types of
information input and against our
biological cultures to see how they
performed. And so, just showing you here
some results where we took the image
vector, which had a CNN to run and
process it and then feed it into the
DPRL algorithms. What we were able to
see actually was that our mouse and
human cells, which are here in Bleu and
orange, significantly outperformed and
outlined DQN was pretty much always
the lowest performer, which is fine, we
know that it's very sample and
efficient. But even more sample
efficient algorithms like A, two C and
PPO also failed to show the
same degree of performance, even though
they started higher. For whatever
reason, we can never quite figure out
just some quirk of the algorithm. They
never showed the same degree of
learning. And this was again mimicked
across multiple comparisons. But what
was brought up to us was this idea of
saying well, there is of course a curve
force dimensionality. So what you're
doing is you're feeding in I think it
was a 40 by 40 image vector to these
deep reinforcement learning. And of
course it's going to take them longer to
converge. They have to deal with more
information. And we went, you know what,
that's a fair point. So what we did was
run it even simpler and we came out and
we said all right, what we'll do is
we'll feed them vectors of simply, you
know, four vector matrix of where the
paddle is and where the ball is and that
will be much simpler and closer to the
game plane. So we fed that into them and
what we saw was actually they formed us
with less information, of course the
mouse and human image time because we
can't alter the information put in this
way it was a post.
Pardon the actual
mouse and human cortical cells but yeah,
they did even worse across and
we found gain they're outperforming. It
more indoctrination than what the
getting because the cells are really
only just received in the ball position.
We're not yet able to encode
proprioception because the disparate
system is very simple. And although we
would argue again that this sparsity of
information should truly make it harder,
not easier with less information and
certainly with our initial pilot testing
we found that the more information you
gave them the better they could do. We
again said fair enough, let's change
the information input to the
reinforcement learning algorithms give
them the simplest possible information
that matches as close as we could
possibly do to what the cells are
getting and see how they performed. And
again they performed even worse
suggesting that in fact more information
is probably helpful. And so I think what
we could show here is that yes there is
certainly something interesting going on
in neural cells and the way they're able
to process information. And it comes
back to this quote that I love so much,
which is to say that if the human brain,
or in this case even a simple collection
of neurons in a dish was so simple that
we could understand it, we might be so
simple that we couldn't. We like to
think that the tools we're building,
such as this, is going to help us to
actually simplify it enough that we'll
be able to unpick and start to
understand the nuances behind this.
But one of the nice things that we're
able to show is that even without fully
understanding all the nuances of what's
going on inside a dish like this we can
see that it does have some distinct
traits in terms of intelligence that
have promising advantages for
information processing above and beyond
what's going on in reinforcement
learning. And we really think this
hammers home that this is going to be a
powerful tool to investigate these
features in more detail. So as
sort of a summed up conclusion what
we're able to do with the system
essentially is have a system of real
biological neurocultures that can
exhibit a very rudimentary form of
natural intelligence through their
inherent adaptive traits. And these
adaptive traits are frankly quite
amazing to the extent and variety and
diversity of what they're shown. And
even with the data that we've already
generated, we're only just scratching
the surface. But there's a lot of
potential that they have. And so simply
by having this closed loop system of
electrophysiological stimulation and
recording via these multilector rays,
we could embed them into or embody them
into a simulated world, depending which
term you prefer. And they could get
better at playing it and moving the
paddle to actually be able to perform
the game with quite a consistent degree
of coordination and with a faster
learning rate than multiple
reinforcement learning algorithms. And
of course, this is as I said, it's a lot
of work and we're only just scratching
the surface. And so one of the things
we're excited to do, because we're
actually not an academic lab, we're a
small start up based in Melbourne,
Australia, is we want to open this
platform up to everybody. So if you have
a question or you think everything I've
just told you is completely wrong and
that neurons work in a totally different
way, that's fine. Reach out. We will
in next year be opening up for alpha
testing. And so the most exciting
projects will be supporting to have an
early access to this. If you want to
investigate the properties of these
neurons, and you have basic Python or
Java coding skills, you can access
them virtually and code them as an
environment and see how they respond and
test it and go away and write a paper
sort of showing how you think that it
should all work based on actual data.
And this is because we acknowledge this
is a whole industry like this or whole
field of research, of course. And so we
want to try and make these tools
available for as many people as
possible, and we're going to make it as
easy for you as possible as well. And
it's going to be fairly affordable.
So that's the end of the talk. And of
course, it's not just me working on
it. There's a whole team and a number of
collaborators that we work with. These
are just the collaborators that sort of
touch on this work. There are many other
very valuable people we work with and
are expanding in other areas. And
actually we're fortunate enough that
Professor Adeel Razi, who's one of our
closest collaborators, has actually been
able to join us today for the discussion
part of it. And so if there are any
discussions, really happy to take
questions.
All right, wow.
Well, thank you very much for that
excellent presentation. It gives us a
lot to jump into.
So perhaps, Adeel, feel free to
say hello, introduce yourself, and add
any general remarks so that we can jump
into some more questions.
>>>ADEEL RAZI: Yes, thank you, Daniel. Great talk, Brett. And as
always, it was a tour de force,
through so many projects that you love
us, is really doing amazing work.
So I'm based at
Minnesota University. We are not that
far from where ecological Labs
is in the city.
We are a bit suburban at
the main campus, Manash University,
where you have this computational system
neuroscience lab. And our
lab is using brain imaging
and computational models, especially
dynamics, causal modeling and active
inference, as frameworks to look into
the brain and try to understand what's
how one can look at the mechanisms,
for example, how the brain implements
cognition. For example. For this we
use, as I said,
mathematical framework of inference
and also dynamic cause of modeling. So
that's basically what we are doing and
happy to contribute to this discussion.
It spreads there
and you should be the one who should be
talking more. And I would be gladly just
sitting here and listening to wonderful
interaction we already have having.
Awesome. Well, my first question just
for context was how did active inference
come together with this line of
research? Were you studying active
inference and then looking for an
embodied system or was it something like
you were studying this very interesting
system and looking for some type of
framework to help you model it?
Absolutely. It's a great question. It
goes back historically. So Andy
Kitchen actually,
who's one of the founders of the
company, they were interested in,
they were looking for ways to explore it
and actually a deal. You ended up having
a conversation with them, I believe,
and they were basically looking for a
method of like, how could we talk to the
cells and they came across active
inference or did you introduce them to
active inference? I would say that
Andy Ari Kahn at that time that we are
talking about late 2018, early 2019,
and they were
already interested in free energy
principle. But then
I just moved to Melbourne from London
in mid 2018 and I end up giving a talk,
ant Alfred, where Cortical lab is being
incubated at that time. And I was
discussing these ideas and it
was kind of interaction
which just happened. And then we
thought, yeah, well, okay, there's lots
of synergy and there
we go. We workshop
some of the early ideas at that time and
thought about on Andy were really
thinking about how to actually what
could be the first thing that we should
do, which would then really
showcase the power of the dish brain.
Of who? The dish brain. Exact name came
later on.
The child? No, actually described as a
name. Definitely goes to Andy as well.
Okay. I would have given it some sort of
esoteric name that everyone would have
gone, what the hell is that? It's a good
call by Andy to do that,
but of course it does have a lot of
really useful features. The whole active
inference framework that make it quite
an ideal thing to test, the whole action
perception cycle, the fact that there
are implications that you can simply
take and be able to test the biological
plausibility of it all, make it very
useful as a system for us to adopt.
Having said that, though, and deal can
attest to this,
I think as a Neil Seth calls it, maybe
other people call it that too. It was a
bit of an adversarial collaboration in
some aspects as well because we were
interested in the idea, but we had no
stake in proving or disproving it. We
were simply testing it. And so we had a
number of discussions as we went through
what if we see x, y and Z?
What would be the states? Just kind of
challenge it, not just support it. And
so I think that was one of the things
that made it a really exciting
collaboration, in that there was a high
degree of skepticism amongst the team
about pretty much everything we did.
And I think that's what came together in
making it quite a nice paper, because we
were like, as everyone should be in
science, but let's be realistic. Seldom
are. We were trying to be our own west
critics because we were trying to figure
out what else could be explaining it.
I think there are interesting future
directions we can explore but certainly
the results as they are did find support
that this only is a key characteristic
of how cells respond.
Awesome so one preemptive question about
learning and then we'll drive back
towards active coherence so what kinds
of mechanisms do the neurons use
to engage game mode and also to learn?
Are they changing their topology in
terms of their connectivity? Are they
changing what happens at synapses? Are
there changes happening inside of cells?
What happens when the game mode turns on
and how does it actually improve
throughout the course of that
experiment? Look, that's a great
question and the reality is we don't
have the full answer for that yet. Most
likely it's going to be a combination of
the latitude. You mentioned changes that
are happening potentially inside cells
or inside synapses. I mean it's not
necessarily too useful to try and break
those apart. The idea of
larger scale morphological changes are
less likely simply due to the timescale
that we see and the fact that we don't
typically, although there will be some
future work sort of showing some other
things as we've moved on and advanced
with our work we typically, in this
study at least, didn't see learning
across days. So it's unlikely there are
massive changes in sort of connectivity.
It's more likely that it's functional
changes in plasticity and how they
respond to information and it could be a
number of things. Of course, it's
probably some sort of relationship and
balance between heavy and homeostatic
plasticity long term potentiation to
long term depression. And then there's
so many mechanisms that you can break
down to look at how that is from one
interesting candidate could be looking
at like foster evolution of coughlin
which interestingly takes I think about
5 minutes to translocate
from inside to outside system absence
and then is known to alter long term
potentiation which would roughly accord
at that time. But this is something we
need to investigate more in the future.
Higher level to that. I mean a deal
might have some ideas to sort of discuss
higher level than this.
Less productive and more high level.
Yeah, more computational.
We are really interested in learning
mechanisms and especially formative
entrance brain of what are the learning
mechanisms that
we can mimic in artificial neural
networks while we have
the biological chip which can learn can
we actually now understand how it's
doing this and can we in the short term
have better artificial neural networks?
Of course, where Brain and his team is
taking to us that we actually don't need
the artificial neural networks anymore,
we'll just have the biological chips.
Right. That's exciting.
So we have been looking at certain
things some of the more unresolved
problems in independent learning and in
machine learning force. Example lifelong
learning and continuum learning where we
know that artificial neural networks,
they break down in tasks.
Where you have to do multiple task
injuries, and they could do very good
human like performances on a single
task, but then you train them on the
second one, and then they forget what
they learned in the first one. Unlike
humans who could run, swim, speak
without forgetting what otherwise
it will be. So that's one thing.
Another thing, credit assignment,
one of the bigger problems. How do you
actually solve the credit assignment
problem, which is again an unsolved long
standing problem in deep learning,
what sort of choices we make
that result in the
boards in culture and many times
what happens there's
a delay in recording what behaviors
resulted in the
reward, for example. So looking ant
what elements and what choices that we
made that resulted in a long term gain
is another problem that we really
don't know right now. How do we actually
going to but these are very big problems
which are unsolved, and I think it
just shows you the power of the dish
brain system that it can actually help
us to I think there's a real
opportunity here for us to actually take
those problems as well at the high
level, as Brett was saying.
And I think it comes down to also being
like the right tool for the right job.
So reinforcement learning,
CNNs can do amazing things if you've got
the data to train them, if you've got
the rest of the setup that you need and
you want to use it for the right
purpose. Are they very good for doing
stuff in dynamic real time with limited
data, fuzzy information? So far,
no. And so maybe there will be a case
where we can take some of the findings
from how neurons work and apply it in an
algorithm in itself. I know
a known Anil and his team are doing some
amazing work with building up active
imprints models and I think those
results are really going to, I think,
excite a lot of people just as some
flagging of some of the work. You're
doing a deal. I won't mention anything
else once you've done that, but it's
going to be really exciting, I think,
for people to see what's happening.
But likewise, I do think that there will
be things that biology maintains
superiority over. The question and the
nice thing about biology, of course,
when you talk about generalized
intelligence, is we have no proof of
principle that generalized intelligence
can arise out of silicon hardware or
quantum based hardware. We do have proof
of principle that it can arise out of
biological wetware our brains and
brains of flies, of cats, of racks,
whatever, show general intelligence to
differing degrees. And so to us it's
like not a question of can biology show
generalized intelligence? But how do you
get there? And that's a less speculative
question, not necessarily an easier
question to answer. It's not easier
necessarily, but it does give you that
ground truth, the thing in Elf itself
sort of answer,
wow. So much there in silicone.
And in principle, systems can display
open ended symbolic learning going back
to the Turing machine, but for the kind
of openended enacted intelligence that
we might be interested in in settings
like you described, which are real time
fuzzy and with small data. And we could
also add with a high risk or survival
threat, those kinds of settings. We have
empirical evidence across the surface of
the planet that biological systems can
make that happen. And we have zero
empirical examples of silicon chips
making that kind of a functionality
arise. So that's a very interesting
point.
That. Kind of brings to this question
about the similarities and the
differences between the artificial
neural networks and the biological
structure and also between the
reinforcement learning paradigm and the
active inference paradigm. In which,
rather than maximizing a reward
function, we are minimizing an expected
free energy or a variational free energy
by way of bounding surprise. So in
describing the experimental setup, the
reward or rather the coherence of
succeeding or failing was you adjusting
the regularity of the input.
And in a reinforcement learning
paradigm, that's a little bit of an
unconventional manipulation one might
expect, oh, well, we'll add sugar or
we'll add a dopamine agonist or an
antagonist to the dish to signal the
positive or the negative valence
directly, kind of by putting our finger
on the scale of the reward function.
But rather you were able to
train and learn by changing the patterns
of regularity of feedback. So how
does active coherence have similarity
and difference with reinforcement
learning in terms of the way that we can
use patterns of regularity, not just
valence of interventions in learning?
I'll give an answer that I'm going to
pass over to a deal who can dive a lot
more into the computational side of it
than what I could.
What I would say, though, is that
there's a few things as well. One of
them, of course, is can you even adopt a
reinforcement learning paradigm in a
dish? It's not like there was a choice
between the two because we don't have
access to a privileged reward network
inside the dish to be able to say good
cells, bad cells. You could like
in theory, squat dopamine in, but you
can't continually squeak dopamine in.
You can't do it in a spatial or temporal
resolution. That's accurate enough,
right? It diffuses slowly. Across media.
We can't do it. So for
us, we needed to find something that was
more fundamental. And I think that's an
important point. And I think it's also
interesting to note, like that there are
studies that look at the fact that you
can mimic changes that you see with
electrical information that you can also
achieve through like the application of
small molecules such as Domain or
whatever neurotransmitters. And the
right stimulation can increase long term
tangential much in the same way that,
say, Dopamine would. And so domain seems
likely to be a tool this is speculative,
of course but it seems likely to be a
tool that shortcuts the
way that these systems work in line with
some broader imperatives such as free
energy minimization more so than being
something unique and special. It is
unique and special in its own right, in
the way that it works. But it must be
serving a more fundamental function.
Yeah, I think that's probably like a
good way then to sort of lead into the
differences between, let's say an active
inference framework and a reinforcement
learning framework which I think a deal
would be best to discuss.
Great question. First we started with
the differences in silicon models
the artificial neural network and the
biological neural network. First of all,
as we see the artificial neural network
is a caricature of an actual biological
neuron. It just mimics that. It takes an
input and then gives
you an output. There's a nonlinear
function and then once you have many of
them and clark them up and
make layers they can do amazing things.
So this is like artificial neural
network just using the virtue
of a cartoon or whatever
biological neural network do. It has a
lot more than that. It is an extremely
complex biological thing.
So imagine now that can
we use all of the power and all the when
it comes to what it can in terms of
information processing and then build
systems, how powerful they will be.
As we know currently,
these huge what
we call these large scale language
models for example, LLMs and then all
those fundamental models that we have
been seeing with billions of
parameters to train them, it requires
gigawatts of power. It's basically like
a whole city can be locked up with once
they train. Now a human brain is just
using a small fraction of inadequate
time and power to do much more than what
they could do. They still can't do solve
causal learning and causal reasoning
problems. Very basics of them. And while
biological neurons can do it very easily
as we are doing it right now we are
having a back and forth discussion that
a big is one of the most sophisticated
and huge neural network would not be
able to achieve even for a few minutes.
So that's what we are looking at.
That's an enormous opportunity that
we have to actually harness this power
and do amazing things now coming
back to coming back active
inference lab and reinforcement
learning. Now, this has
been asked many times and there are
papers that Karl has written, I think
Nullsaid has a paper on where they look
at Hohwy what
is biological. So I think active
coherence is biologically plausible.
So the main difference is
that when you are an active inference
system is optimizing a single quantity,
what we call the free energy of racial
free energy and that
gives you with a single optimization
function you are doing perception
planning and decision making with the
same quantity. So let me put this this
way think that how things have happened
over the past few decades that it has
been always been about how to optimize a
function. So once you have, let's say,
a value function or what in
reinforcement, learning is all about how
best you can optimize this quantity.
While what we are asking, we are saying
that what is we are optimizing, not how.
We optimize. So what is that quantity?
And that's the ratio for energy that we
are optimizing. And it gives you all of
that in a single compared to a
reinforcement learning system that would
require multiple objective functions to
optimize. So I think it's not
biologically taenable to have that.
And that's why the active inference is
a unifying framework and it probably
would rattle and offend few that we
think that active infant subsumes all
those computational
framework like reinforcement learning
into dynamic programming and all those
derivatives because it is basically
what the brain are doing and they are
doing it better than what framework
that we have Beren using so far. So I
think there are differences, clear
differences. However,
having said that, I would really would
like to see in future probably
we probably will have a dig at it how
you can actually mathematically which
chaos then become unambiguously sure
provided proof. That.
Active inference lab appear so there is
still a gap there. While we could
develop insulate active inference agents
and we can show them that they are doing
better than reinforcement learning
agents and then we have quite a few.
There's a whole sort of work that
my PhD student Ashwin Paul is doing and
the papers are coming where we are
comparing active coherence agents with
the state of the art with learning and
deep learning networks and
we are showing of course active
inference lab is doing better
but theoretical proofs are still
missing. Similarly like active inference
lab, what are
the similarities and differences? For
example, I would be very interested to
know how it's different from Tudorov's
work. Again, Ashwin is looking at that.
I am in all trudeau's paper, PNAS paper
in 2009 which looks at efficient
computations optimal action which hae
Parr reaching. They show that you can
both in discrete and continuum settings.
They have shown that their algorithms
can beat dynamic programming and
children learning based algorithms.
Active inference lab is different from
fish, prize bottle, information
bottleneck.
What are the links between universal
tries of Solomonov, all those
things? It's really early days.
What are the similarities and
differences of active entrance with all
those big ideas which are there for you
in Serbanetics and another literature
for many, many years, for decades? What
are the differences and in similarities?
It's a good question. We don't have all
the answers but it
would be very exciting next year is
looking at all those big questions.
I just wanted to echo one point you made
and then ask a question from the Chat.
So in reinforcement learning what
you should optimize is almost treated as
an obvious question. You want to win the
game, you want more points, that's the
way to win. You want to stay alive,
then you want to optimize survival so
that's your reward function. And what to
optimize is kind of swept under the rug.
And then there's this big question of
how to optimize it. And that's what has
led to this enormous diversification of
different approaches and heuristics for
how to optimize and different gradient
descent methods and so on in
reinforcement learning. In contrast, in
active inference, what to optimize is
actually known. It's the variational or
the expected free energy as exactly
specified by the generative model and we
know how to optimize it, which is with a
variety of locally plausible
biologically inspired update rules, for
example, message passing and belief
propagation. So that's a very subtle but
also paradigmatic difference which is
that the structure of what we're going
to optimize as our unified imperative
for perception, cognition and action.
The free energy functional has methods
and software packages that will step by
step convergently optimize it.
And so the onus is actually to specify
the generative model in a useful way
rather than treating what should be
optimized as just a bygone discussion
and then go into all these questions
about implementation which are the parts
that actually differ the most across
systems. So I think that's very
insightful. I wanted to ask a question
from the Chat, from Michael what would
be the difference if you change the
electrode array to stimulate
differently? For example, instead of
just growing the neurons on top, what if
the neuron synapses with the electrodes?
So what kinds of experimental setups are
possible and which ones are interesting
and how do you know and what do you
choose to do? I think the first
thing to say about that good question.
And certainly as the technology develops
we'll be able to ask these questions in
better and more interesting ways. It's
probably worth well, I've made this
comparison before, but I'll make it
again. The work that we've done here is
we're excited by it but at the same time
it is probably equivalent to the early
transistors made by Shockley. It's
janky, it's kind of ugly. It does a job
but not without limitations. And so
what we're really excited in is as the
community hopefully come together and
work on this 510,
1520 years, maybe longer.
70 years of continuum development have
led from a transistor being a large ugly
thing to thousands of them within every
device that I can see. So that's like
one thing I'll just say in terms of,
like, I will point out that the neurons
do, inasmuch as they probably ever can
integrate with the electrodes as is as
you saw from that picture I showed at
the start, they are deeply integrated
into the electrode.
We could not and let the neuron survive,
remove them in any meaningful way and
keep that structure. To get them, we'd
have to completely like disassociate
their structure and most neurons won't
survive that for very long anyway,
so they are currently integrated.
Synapses work slightly differently.
There's a whole collection of traits.
Like, there is, of course, electrical
activity is a shared language between
neurons and the hardware and that's
what makes it possible to stimulate them
with electricity because it can sort of
mimic the change in ions across the
membrane to stimulate action potentials,
which is how they then communicate with
electricity. But then action potentials,
of course, trigger the release of
chemical signals and so forth. So
there's a lot that's going on there and
I think it's about building the bridge.
It's not necessarily about,
I don't know, quite the right word
phrases about completely recapturing
everything that's unique to biology and
the hardware all unique to the hardware
in biology. It's about where's the
useful bridge and synthesis between
them to elicit the best of both worlds.
And again, it comes down the right tool
for the right job. But in this case,
it's like a different circumstance.
Like what's the right tool to process
the information? Is it a biological
Parr? Is it the hardware part? And so
when we communicate with them, what we
need to figure out and again, this is an
open question. I'm not sure where it
will go. But what we need to figure out
is what's the best way? At the time of
the technology we have right now, it's
not trying to replicate sort of
hardware based synapses to do sort of
chemical communication. Although maybe
in the future it will be. But yeah,
it's a very interesting question and the
base of the answer is we don't really
know where it could go and we don't know
where it would do. As I mentioned, the
talk, they are incredibly plastic
neurons. We can change the
configuration, we can change the type of
neurons, we can move from two D to three
D. And this is work that we have ongoing
now. And I think that what we're going
to see is just an explosion of results
as we start to make inroads in this
area.
Saying that the neurons might not
survive the separation from their cyber
physical digital substrate reminds me of
the reality of some to all of us
today. If we were also stripped from our
digital substrate, many critical systems
also would not function. And I think
that speaks to some of the recent Karl
J. Friston et al versus with
the idea of the ecosystems of shared
intelligence where we're thinking about
distributed cognitive processes that are
mediated by interfaces. And so some
emitted data set is received by another
cognitive entity on the other side of
the blanket and maybe it's person to
person, maybe it's computer to computer
or something mixed or some augmented
system, but there's a really tractable
and elegant way to talk about those
heterogeneous systems. So even if in the
local context one algorithm or another
outperforms another, there's going to be
an immense value for using active
inference and FEP to just talk about how
to compose these systems. And so that's
very important. Insight 100%
that's a really good point, Daniel.
Like very valuable. And it comes down,
I think fully agree with you. It comes
down to how do we phrase and think about
these even? And that's a challenge.
Even discussing what these systems are
and what they're showing is a challenge
right now. And we need to work on
building up that language together so we
can have those useful discussions and
figure out how to leverage this
distributed network that we're all I
think it's inevitable that you bring up
that's where we are and so we're only
going to go deeper down that direction.
Awesome. Just a little bit of some
questions on information as we head
towards the end. It was a very striking
finding about the changes in information
dynamics when gameplay was activated
versus rest as well as during learning.
And also that's kind of analogized by,
let's say, a person in an fMRI and
they're mind wandering, they're engaging
the default mode, and then some task
comes on and the information dynamics
sharpen and we associate that with the
mechanisms of attention. So how did you
measure or quantify the information or
what dot one informational measures mean
in the context of neural firing
patterns?
Yeah, that's a big question. And again,
it's something that we need to do more
work at diving into to actually and pick
about what it actually means at this
point, what we're limited to look,
well, that's not entirely true. We're
not led to it. What we did look at,
just for the sake of time and
complexity, were individual spikes in a
given location. And so you can arrange
that spatially and temporarily. And so
what we've looked at and we've dived
into this more work with our recent work
with Organoids as well, trying to pick
apart sort of the sub functional
subunits of computation or intelligence
or whatever word you want to use. But
yes, essentially what it is is it's the
pattern of activity you're seeing across
time and space for a given spike in a
location versus the other one. And so
there's a number of ways you can look at
this. I think the really exciting stuff
that's coming out is around sort of
trying to break apart. So people started
hodgkin huskily models, et cetera, they
looked at neurospiking and they were
like how does a single neuron spike,
what makes a single neuron spike? And
they came up with some rules that are
mostly true, but now we know are kind of
still wrong because many neurons
follow those rules and many do not. And
some are circumstance dependent.
And then people have sort of extended
that and they looked at how a given
system change its activity over time.
And then, of course, you can expand that
out and look at like, how do pairs of
neurons and then trios of neurons and
grow that up into a whole population?
And so what we've tried to do with this
work that I've sort of shared with you
today is look at that at a few different
levels and so depending the level
depends the exact answer to what is
information. But essentially
the simplest answer is it's the spikes
that we can see in this case going on
and their relationships to other spikes?
I don't know, Dean might have more to
expand on that. No, I think Beren I
think at some point we also as you
mentioned, we want to look at those
functional subunits, considering using
those main field models, using those
function units as neural
populations and then hopefully they
emergence like a few functional
subunits. And then can we look at
connectivity patterns using something
like a neural mass models which have
been used quite a lot,
something like a gentle width models,
but bit more dynamics in them.
And so that would be really interesting
to see how the patterns
are emerging, when neurons learn, how
the patterns are foraging patterns and
connections and how
these are changing over time as more and
more learning is happening. And that
would be something we are talking about
lots of unknowns and lots of very
interesting directions that one can
take, which makes it all exciting.
And I think our thinking also at least
my thinking has changed over the course
of looking at this. When I started out,
I kind of thought well, an individual
neuron is the smallest functional unit
theoretically, right? So that's probably
what's going on and then they'll connect
up and then I realized, well, I think
like, yeah, it is a single neurons, a
functional unit, but so are two neurons
and three neurons and the collective
exponential growth as you go out to
whole pattern. And at the end of day
when we look at actually at the levels
we Beren looking at, for example,
criticality, if you go look at a
preprint, we broke it down into areas
like sensory verse, motor areas and we
found that they all kind of behave more
or less the same. So does that mean that
under dish we have one functional unit
or 800,000 or everything
in between and looking at the organoid
stuff that we've moved to that that
we're not quite ready to share yet. But
I think what we can sort of start to
tentatively conclude from this work is
that it is indeed that answer of like
one to the combination of the
everything. And I think that's what
makes the biological systems and this is
why I emphasize it in my talk. Look at
the amount of connectivity and sort of
chaotic connectivity to some extent
that's occurring within these systems.
And that gives you something that we
can't model with neuromorphic or with
algorithms, with any degree of with
the same traits. At least I think I can
say without being too controversial with
the same traits. We can't yet model that
algorithmically yet. And I think that
makes it interesting as well.
Awesome. One just remark on that before
kind of a closing discussion. The
Hodgkin Huxley models were on
large single isolated neurons.
And so a theme I heard you say multiple
times was like the right tool or the
right model in the right concept. And so
when studying sodium and potassium flow
across the membrane of a single isolated
neuron, that is absolutely an
appropriate model and something that
provided immense insights. And then,
as you pointed out, especially if you're
interested in properties of systems and
connected neurons, it's like a yes,
and there are sodium flows.
But you could imagine concepts where
learning happens and the informational
pattern or the entropy of a given neuron
does change. Or it might not change,
but the pairwise relationship might
change. Or the pairwise relationship
might not change. But some higher order
relationship does change. And so that
doesn't replace mechanistic or smaller
subunit based models. But rather we
can broaden the discussion to thinking
even about the environment, like of the
dish or of our peripersonal space that
these cognitive systems are embedded in
and talk about distributed cognitive
functions without privileging the
ecological or the sort of atomic levels
of explanation. Yeah, absolutely. And
thank you for clarifying that if I sort
of implied otherwise. Awesome.
Just to highlight, because despite
the ring on the COVID of the active
inference textbook, there isn't a single
model to rule them all. And I think it's
really by getting into the particulars
of experiments and also by speaking with
researchers and by talking about this
kind of cutting edge research that we
see how pluralism in the methodological
and in the explanations actually plays
out. And that's just very exciting. So I
guess just a closing question and then
we can just have any other remarks.
Michael asks in the chat, what should
someone study or do to get more involved
with this research? I'm an undergraduate
student interested in pursuing this
field for my career and I'd love to work
with Cortical Labs.
I think it really depends the Brea you
want to go down. We're always looking
for good people to work with and as I
said, before. This is going to be a
whole industry and a whole field of
research. We hope and believe, anyway.
So I guess you should pick what it
is that interests you and what you're
passionate about. There's so much stuff
going on, right? You could study
electrical engineer, you could study
physics, you could study software
engineering, you could study
neuroscience, you could study stem cell
biology, anything in between.
These are multidisciplinary,
highly collaborative outputs.
I showed the team before. We have people
from all of those industries and others,
and it's only the combination of these
areas that give rise
to the chance to actually make something
that it's the gestalt, right? It's
greater than the sum of its parts. And I
think, honestly, that's one of the
reasons why we've had some success
coming from a sort of start up industry
focus, is that there's not that many of
us and we don't have that much money.
But what we do have is, like, an amazing
team of people to work with, amazing
collaborators, like a deal to work with,
and we can bring it all together in one
spot. And that's hard to do by its
nature. And academia, like, by its
nature, academia tends to silo, and you
have exceptions to that rule, of course.
You have very highly collaborative works
that do come out of academia, but they
are always I worked in academia.
They're always at a distance, those
collaborations. They're not all under
one roof with one goal and
one purpose.
Any general comments, feel free to
respond to that. And also just any
general thoughts you want to add? I was
to say I cannot recommend enough
cortical labs. They are highly
multidisciplinary team with expertise
from cell biology to software
engineering to real time interfacing,
to computational models and machine
learning. So anything that
your expertise and you want to do,
there would be something that's there
and really cutting edge,
I think. There's this whole project, it
just shows the whole breadth of things
that we can do, from neurons to sentient
behavior. And I'm cutting my back for
saying sentient sentence today, which
hasn't been Sajid.
And I should say Brea is also leading a
project on that site, which we didn't
get chance to talk about, the nonclature
and all that. That happens with the
semantics of sentence and consciousness
and agency and all that and
the whole ethic side of thing.
There are big opportunities and
questions open, challenges.
And I think actually do you make a
good point. I should use this
opportunity, if I may, Daniel, at least
a two flag. Yeah, we are we are engaging
in a number of paper, so if you are
interested in the words that we use,
whether you think that we use them
correctly or incorrectly, we would
invite anyone. We've made these offers
before, but it's a great place to say it
again, reach out. We are setting up,
and we will have a formal invitation
somewhat soon. I can't exactly say when
because there's so much going on at the
moment, but fairly soon we'll have an
invitation. Come join us. Let's work
together and just figure out what
language we want to use as a community,
because then we can move towards
actually building some stuff instead of
just being caught up with, like, what
does this word mean? And that's going to
be necessary. So, yeah, please. Great
chat to us. Yeah. I'll just note one
project at the Institute, which is
active coherence lab ontology where
we've been developing definitions and
also translations across languages of
core and supplemental terms, and we use
that to annotate papers. We make natural
language descriptions of mathematical
formalizations, and we totally agree
that ontology based systems engineering
for active inference, cyber, physical
systems is how we're going to treat this
with the respect. And also bring in the
discussions around ethics, philosophy
and so on. So this isn't a linguistics
debate that excludes other Fields. This
is like laying down the dance floor so
that we can actually have a discussion
that's inclusive and meaningful going
forward, which is what is so important.
That's awesome. I got to look force
stuff. I didn't know that you guys had
one of those. I'm going to have a look
up later. I'll send it to you in an
email. Well, thank you so much. What an
awesome line of research and a December
surprise or treat for us. So super
exciting. And please always feel welcome
to just reach out and join for any other
time. Awesome. Thank you so much,
Daniel, for having us and everyone
watching. All right, bye bye. Thank you.
Bye.